as con said I'm the program manager open
source science OSI is a initiative out
of num Focus that's trying to brid
between open source developers and open
source resch of research software and
the users of that research software so
I'm sure know uh there seem to be some
bugs in the open source
research Tim it does look like you have
an
echo mute Maybe
awesome awesome
um wait is this still
echoing ah we'll keep going we'll see
what happens uh so there seem to be some
bugs in the open source science stack
for research software um where oh man
where even start if you're a researcher
for example and you're you just want to
do one simple thing uh you're presented
with this ecosystem of just so much
software to choose from that it's kind
of overwhelming and oftentimes you'll
end up just building your own tool your
own software to do a very
specific thing for your research when in
reality you could have just probably
built a little little edit into some uh
research software that already exists
with the support of a giant Community
behind that research software that
already exists uh and the result of this
problem where people are creating their
own Professor Weare maybe uh is that you
get some really cool software that just
dies as soon as the person who created
in the first place for their very
specific use case uh moves on to either
another institution another project or
or just doesn't have time anymore to to
support that research software so that's
just one example of one of the bugs that
might be in the uh open source research
software
stack so our hope at OSI is by
connecting the uh the wide ecosystem of
um open source research software
directly to researchers we can prevent
that problem and many others and at the
same time give a lot of added value to
researchers and developers of Open
Source research software uh along the
way so um maybe you can you can think of
it like product Discovery or user
experience Discovery or or user feedback
in a simple way and one of the ways we
want to do that is through Moss the map
of Open Source science there are other
ways we're we're doing this as well
there are a bunch of interest groups we
have uh that you're very welcome to join
um if you email me I will connect you to
all those or go to that QR code I think
that will link you to the uh Moss
interest group only but there are
there's one in chemistry Life Sciences
climate
sustainability uh reproducible
science um and that's all that comes up
at the top of my head but there are a
couple more as well but Moss
is a let me just show
you okay so uh disclaimer before we
begin this little demo of what we're
building here uh this is a very early
proof of concept we're just trying to
experiment with what's possible when it
comes to visualizing the open source
software uh research software ecosystem
in a graph
visualization so there's going to be
data in here and information that we've
just put in his placeholders there's
going to be some information data that's
not entirely not 100% accurate but kind
of accurate uh and and just bear keep
that in mind as we're going through it
but let's start with
this so this is the open source research
uh software ecosystem around only num
Focus these are num Focus projects and
num Focus peoples that we've mapped so
this is barely tip of the iceberg
although n Focus does uh physically
sponsor many opensource uh research
software projects the little orange dots
let's zoom in a little
bit little orange dots you can see down
here's the key are packages green dots
are
people uh the red dots are projects down
here uh yellows are papers and I think
we added our first paper though I'm not
sure if this version of the map is
updated and then the orange dots are
organizations and it does look like this
map is updated so we get to explore the
paper route for the first time today I
think but this is this is crazy if
you're a researcher and this is
essentially a visual visualization of
the ecosystem you enter when you're
trying to figure out what tool to use or
who to reach out to to help you build
some software to do your research so the
goal is to simplify that process and we
can walk through a couple um uh stories
about how that might work and for the
sake of my computer because this is all
processed locally I'm going to remove
people from this map
uh so we don't freeze so I'll add it
back later so we can hopefully as long
as my computer doesn't crash when I do
it visualize the entire ecosystem map
and all the connections and everything
but right now we're just looking at
organizations packages and projects here
is gome focus when you click one of the
nodes um you can see the information
that we populate the map with all of
this is graph information all of this is
inputed Fields um about any project and
package so let's just
see what it looks like when we map all
the fiscally sponsored projects to num
focus and you can already see sort of
where this is going to go so num focus
is the fiscal sponsor to all of these
projects KN bable num P you get all the
the information here the little blurb
and then um essentially a database right
here and this database is going to end
up getting very complicated very quick
very text Heavy very quick uh and which
is why we think a visualization is going
to be very
helpful so let's say we are a researcher
entering the machine learning space for
the first time uh and we want to know
what possible tools like we know nothing
about what tool exist for us to use and
we want to learn what possible tools we
could use and then if we want to learn
more about these tools who we can reach
out to our organizations we can reach
out to so let's remove fiscal
sponsors and uh please don't yell at me
about ontologies uh we had to make some
decisions about what is what's here but
let's map every project that deals with
a um field of science we've mapped it
currently into subdomains
subfields um and domains
so you can see this big orb right here
in data science
and uh another disclaimer the metrics
we're using to uh visualize the size
which correlates to the importance of
various packages and projects people are
very inaccurate they they're the easiest
numbers we can find currently but we've
got now uh a bunch of sub uh subfields
here um and we can search
for machine learning
here's the machine learning subfield
and let's focus only on that subfield
because as a researcher that's what
we're entering this field that's what
we're interested in let's show the
names and there we go with a couple
clicks we now see several projects that
we should probably explore if we want to
start looking into machine learning and
the tools that we can use for
this now we want to go a little deeper
so let's see if we've mapped any
packages of these projects like we have
not but once we do you'll be able to see
all the packages uh and get a little
deeper into each one of these projects
that are
related but maybe we have mapped uh some
complimentary tools that are used often
in conjunction with these oh you know
what it is I need to expand my focus
there we
go so we've got machine learning here we
can go down to this one looks easy to
read P torch and we can see that all of
these tools are also uh complementary to
pytorch so maybe if I want to start
using pytorch as my primary tool I
should look at uh these more granular
tools as
well
so you can start to see the process here
and you can expand even further you can
get more in detail more in depth with
just whatever you want to do and it
starts to get very noisy for a specific
use space but very cool for visualizing
very quickly so we'll stop
here there's another interesting use
case
[Music]
um with the map let's remove all the
connections go over with really quickly
let's remove our focus and we're back to
that basemap uh let's say we have found
a security flaw with map plot
Li so we're going to find and we need to
figure out who to let know about the
security flaw and what else might be
affected by the security flaw so now we
have Matt plot lib as our
focus and we know that fiscal sponsors
are generally speaking good people to
reach out to good organizations that
support the projects and can give us a
little more information about this and
we won't be bothering the uh core
development team or the maintainers of
this open source project at the same
time so right away we can see that we're
gonna reach out to num
Focus to talk to them about the security
flaw really quick and and get some
guidance and what we should do with it
and here's other information Etc that's
awesome that was very quick now let's
say we're a large organization or
institution and we want to figure out in
worst case scenario
what is going to be affected by this
security
flaw so we're going to map the
dependencies related to map notl and
this constant moving is a um feature of
the software we're using to build out
this brief concept it's called kumu kumu
is really cool for a graph visualizer by
the way would recommend checking it out
um but we've mapped the dependencies now
and we can see that all of these
projects are dependent on matplot lib so
if there is indeed a critical flaw M
plot Li which there is not but this
scenario we're saying there is uh then
we can we're going to have to explore
the effect on all of these other
projects and whether or not we can
continue using
them uh now let's
say
whoops go back to
M now let's say we're that there is a
critical flaw in it and we need to
figure out what we can do because we
need to keep
using uh applying the the features of
matplot lib but we can't use matplot lib
anymore apply the utility of it so we
need to find out what else we might be
might possibly use to get the same
utility so let's map the
Alternatives the map and here we go we
see that it's possible that some of
these projects do similar stuff to M as
Mt plot uh so these are projects worth
exploring maybe reaching out to their
fiscal sponsors uh they might know a
little more about what might be a good
alternative see now which ones
are again let's just go
here see which one of the packages are
officially sponsored by num Focus so
maybe we go to boka and go out to num
Focus to see if this is a good
replacement for what we need or if
there's features we can add to this uh
open source package to to fulfill our
needs so there's two stories there for
utilities
and um all right we've got some time so
I'm going to try to find the
paper you know what it's only one paper
and I'd have to oh I think I remember
which one it was
uh but I haven't coded the the paper
connection yet all right so we'll ignore
the paper thing for now but one
interesting thing I did just map uh the
other day move all our
connections and let's conect everything
to sub
Fields so let's say I'm a researcher and
I just need to visualize some data from
my research so I just mapped the the the
visualization little ecosystem so I now
see the subfield visualization and I see
all of these packages are related uh to
visualization in some way and what we'll
be able to do in the future is
uh
wonder if it works now uh it sort of
does okay so I search for a tag
dashboarding and it looks like I can use
Jupiter Flex for
dashboarding um in the future I'm not
sure if this is possible for with kumu
but in um the the iteration where we're
building this outside of kumu what we
want to happen there is only the nodes
that are for dashboarding would appear
and everything else would disappear so
the user could find all the packages for
dash boarding and then um there would be
more information here to help guide them
to the correct tool or the most
appropriate tool for their specific use
case and you can think of llms as they
start to develop more uh and be able to
interact with graph
databases if I just type in natural
language hey I need to visualize this
data and build a dashboard for it and I
I'm working in Python and uh my working
in geology or something like that uh it
the llm will be able to scan the graph
and give us back some some good use case
some good packages some good tools to
use for a specific use case that's going
to be very neat uh when that gets built
in that's not anywhere in the shortterm
road map though uh so this is moss those
are a couple stories going very quickly
into what we we hope the capabilities of
this map um will provide the the papers
aspect of it will hopefully tell another
story besides a researcher looking for a
tool to use in the research or a um uh
someone who's found a security flaw
looking for who to contact andoss
dependency implications andoss
Alternatives uh and this third story
will be impact of a tool uh a lot of
these open source tools have uh dois and
can be cited and despite it not being as
much as we would hope they are cited and
so we want to map all the papers that
site these specific tools um so that we
can visualize the the paper impact and
whether or not that's technical impact
or not goes into the metrics definitions
that we're also exploring which are very
fun conversations that everyone is
invited to join uh but we'll be able to
visualize all the papers that come out
of these these tools and then all the
products that come out of those papers
and we'll really be able to see and and
show how important how foundational open
source research software is to Society
at large uh not just research but to
everything you know and to bring in llms
again because they are still very hyped
a lot of these packages and tools are
foundational to Ai and llm so we need to
show that in this map so that funders uh
and supporters of open- source research
software open source software in general
understand how their their funding
impact the world around them and then
can also use that to to show off uh how
impactful they are in the world um
hopefully if we start mapping citations
as well and then the people connected to
the papers that are citing this open-
Source software those people who are
incentivized by citations and and social
reputation and social graphs will be
more incentivized to site this open
source software because time they cite a
paper they get put on this map and their
Circle grows bigger they're they're more
easily uh identifiable on the map simply
because they cited the software they're
already using so there's a lot of
Downstream effects we hope mapping this
system and making it a visual uh and an
interactive visual have because one of
the the uh hopeful outcomes of this
development is that it will be an
entirely composable map so whatever I
want to do with the database that's
visualized in this map I can do it
depending on my context whatever my
context is with regards to the open
source research software ecosystem and
what I need to find there will be this
database that is managed by a Commons or
or the open source ecosystem and uh I
can visualize that database however I
want and explore it through Lans or
whatever other means I desire so before
we get into Q&A or any discussions uh I
want to start trying to map the entire
ecosystem just so we can see um what how
powerful a visualization is I'm trying
to think of the best way to do this
without my crash in my
computer so I'm going to show people but
I'm only going to show people who have
committed to these open source
repositories more than 10 times and uh
this highlights you know the the fault
of one of the metrics we using which is
the the size of these people circles as
determined by the number of commits
they've made they've made to the repos
to the projects we mapping that's
obviously not a good indicator of
contributions to these projects it
actually excludes a lot of Originators
of the packages of the projects um but
it is an easy way to start mapping this
stuff and also control how many of these
circles show up so that when we start
drawing the lines again the computer
doesn't crash so let's map people to
projects
that looks
like ski the be
there very cool let's do the easy one
here projects to fiscal
sponsors we might freeze if we freeze uh
and I disconnect Tim please take
off um okay let's map uh packages to
projects so I I packages to projects for
example is good for um projects like
astropy which is a collection of a lot
of packages and in itself is not
necessarily a singular package or tool
but it's it is a singular tool it's a
singular project but it's comprised of
many different packages um now let's
map projects to sustaining parent orgs
and packages to sustaining and parent
orgs and the only little sub ecosystem
that has been mapped with these is the
visualization section I just
added so let's actually see if we can
see yeah you can see all these
organizations out here support open-
Source visualization in some way and one
of the most interesting ones I found so
far
um if we can find it snowflake Spotify
Spotify has supported open source
research or open source visualizing
tools at some point which is really
interesting I'm looking forward to
talking to them and figuring out why
what else they're doing and and how we
can get them to support more open source
software because look they're on the map
because they they supported open source
research software and okay we're
starting to see this map take place or
take shape here uh let's map uh people
to packages and I think we'll stop there
and as this
renders oh no on you can do
it uh happy to take any questions if
anything has coming um we're happy to
just have a discussion as well if anyone
has any thoughts I'll throw up the QR
code again at the end uh and I will also
say that this is very much a community
initiative um we're leading it out of
OSI it's largely me and Tim building
this thing we have two other people who
are helping build us um Mark and someone
else who's just joining us we have
working groups we have the interest
group which meets once a month for just
the discussion on overall strategy
Direction what we're doing how we're
doing it that sort of thing knowledge
sharing and then we have a working group
that meets once a week uh and we just
work on this thing talk about any
problems that we're having as we're
building it for example being able to
map papers came out of that working
group
uh where we just sat down and found the
dois for every package we've mapped so
far if you work with a tool just re
that's not on the map you can just reach
out to me uh or him and we will do our
best to add it and as we build this
thing out uh we are prioritizing proof
of concepts of each story along the way
and because we are using kumu which is
very very good for smaller
visualizations uh and but not it starts
to get Limited and capability as we get
bigger we're going to have to choose
what we add to this map just so we can
be sure we can tell all these stories
with this proof of
concept I can keep talking unless there
are any questions Tim did anything yeah
thanks so much this is great I'm
answering questions in the Q&A I'm
answering them um for example you know
how where can I use
this an app yet that's ready for
starting to prototype next year another
question what add to that is we are
looking into licensing uh so that we can
because this is kumu you can see up here
is private we want to make it public so
people can start playing around with it
the issue is licensing it so that we
keep it under n focused and hopefully we
will be able to release this m which is
completely interactive for anyone wants
to play with it you can see the database
and all of that sometime next year but
don't hold me to that hopefully
soon yeah another question was whether
this is only python project it is not
we're not limited to any particular
programming language as as long as it's
related to science we want it on the map
Y and I'll map languages here for a
second there so the the reason it is a
lot of python projects right now is
because a lot of num Focus fiscally
sponsored projects which is where we're
starting our python projects but there
are a couple R and Julia projects on
well here as
well somebody what tool we're using and
I mentioned we're using kumu we love
kumu this has been awesome um to get us
this far and to just play with some of
these and Concepts and I hope that if
you use your imagination you can see
where lead you know once it gets onto
like a real like a like a solid app that
supports um you know advanced search and
analytics and visualization tools and so
yeah hope that and I will point out if
anyone's interested in getting involved
we
are on that architectural level we're
exploring NE is a possible uh language
and and back end to build this outside
of kumu so if you know neo4j or
comfortable with it love to
talk somebody
just obviously I think we're we're
hitting the limits really hard of what
kumu can can support I've never seen a
map with this many um you know uh nodes
in it so it takes a while for these
things to render in kumu however in the
future I think once we have an actual
you know Standalone app with the proper
architecture I think we will be able to
solve those
issues
yes we expect um Millions if not
hundreds of millions of nodes at some
point because think about the open
source feature software and then this is
still people who have fewer than 10
commits so I'm GNA click this might
actually crash
um I'm just gonna click everyone and see
what
happens it's so cool to see I love it
every
time
you can see start to see just how useful
this messy seemingly messy visualization
of the graph of the ecosystem is um as
we we start to put in more metrics you
see this person has done a
lot to for something we can click that
Noe and explore what see this
organization which of just Happ to know
is down focus seems to be an anchor for
this little section of the map at least
um these projects out here seem to be
very
Niche uh these everything in here seems
to be fairly core to what's going on in
open source research
software and and as we build more
organizations and little microcosms of
the larger larger
space only G to become more useful I'm
very excited for what
happens
hi
Jonathan have time for just one last
question
um let me bring a question for you on
screen vertices and yeah I was just
talking about that it's gonna be um very
large like right now it's I think 10,000
nodes is plus or minus 3,000 and then
connections wise
um it would have to be complete guess
but I would guess 30 to
50,000
um complete guess though it's it's hard
to because the way the database is
formatted it's difficult to just look at
the cell
number but if there are any questions or
if you want to get involved please do
out
johnj
nfocus scan this QR code you can that'll
take you directly to some more links you
can learn more about OSI because we do
do other stuff
um and I do invite you to join because
this is a community we're trying to
build this best weekend with this
community we want input we want your
Heth building it